okay let's see huh this one should be
interesting
hey everybody how are we doing tonight
oh oh I love hot cider high point of my
slow shift was delivering groceries to a
customer who had a pet pig ah ha ha ha
sound cute hello from Australia lovely
glad to have you here salutations and to
you hello evening just woke up from a
nap how was your weekend my weekend was
ok please don't call me Nate no Connor
I'll answer to a lot of things but not
that just got my driver's license today
Oh congratulations on your first try
hahaha happy nah no remo yes to anyone
who is who is undergoing that I'm
actually not this year first time in a
while I haven't tried to do that which
is just as well because I've never
succeeded at it anyways
if I can finish a crow sit crochet plush
during your stream that sounds adorable
merchandise of the daleks oh boy is this
a sander stream not exactly calling you
nate is worse than capitalism about on
par okay so I should explain a couple of
things about this entire premise that
I've got going on who do you think is a
better Britpop band blur or super grass
I don't know either of those so I
couldn't tell you anyways it's not hot
chocolate it's hot cider but you may
have guessed part of the desire to do
this stream was the video that I put up
today talking about what's going on with
YouTube because to put very simply all
the things going on with YouTube right
now can be traced very directly to
capitalism and the way that it works and
honestly a lot of problems can be traced
to capitalism now here's the first thing
and I suspect I will have to reiterate
this as the night goes on I don't know
what would be better and I some people
go well don't bring up the problems if
you don't have a solution I'm like I you
know what much smarter people than me
have failed to come up with a solution
that doesn't remove my right to point
out problems first of all so no I'm not
a communist I'm not saying that you know
here's my basic operating premise the
unfettered version of any governing
system doesn't work it always has to be
tempered I mean the unfettered version
of democracy doesn't work true pure
democracy would mean that everyone gets
a vote on every major decision that
would be a disaster that will be a mess
so just broadly speaking I think no
matter what system you're doing it has
to be tempered because basically no core
car
cept his bulletproof so I don't have a
problem with the inherent concept of
capitalism I do have a problem with the
current system of capitalism or actually
I can be super specific on this I have a
problem with investment capitalism I
have a problem with the concepts of
shareholders I have a problem with the
idea of getting money simply for having
money which is what investing is I have
massive problems with that and I can
even pinpoint the moment that I first
developed my inherent distaste for that
I could not I didn't realize that that
was the reason it happened but this was
a big moment in my life one of my early
jobs when I was in college the job I had
I worked at a Barnes & Noble I worked
part time so I remember having a meeting
this was during my first year there this
was after the holiday rush I remember
being told I cannot remember I think
they had like the regional manager show
up to tell us this I'm a little iffy on
that detail but I remember very
distinctly being told that the business
we had done that year was 15% better
than the year before and then that was
immediately followed by it wasn't good
enough because the expectation was we
were gonna do 25% better than the year
before something in that moment clicked
in my brain like wait we did better than
last year but you're still telling us we
did badly what of course now I know the
reason for that is investment capitalism
because your standard run-of-the-mill
capitalism where people make things and
then sell those things for
but whether that be a physical thing an
entertainment thing a digital thing
whatever or whether that thing be a you
know a service that you provide with
your time whatever that thing be you
provide that service or that thing you
get paid for it but investment
capitalism demands that you not just be
profitable that you be that you show
growth because investors demand return
on investment so it's not enough to
simply be profitable being profitable is
actually just on its own is actually
failing if you're profitable but not
growing because if a company a only a
company that has no investors can get
away with simply making a thing and
selling a thing at a profit you know
making enough money to continue to make
whatever they make and pay everyone a
fair wage and then have a little bit
left over that is not good enough the
instant investors get involved it has to
grow year over year this is why
companies like Disney as big as they are
it is not at least I don't believe an
inherent desire of the people at Disney
I don't think it's an inherent desire of
say Bob Iger for Disney to own literally
any everything but they have to they
have to keep acquiring companies they
have to keep swallowing up other things
because at this point that's the only
way for something that big keep growing
and that is what investors demand I'm
getting a really direct taste of this
entire process at my day job right now
because we were bought out by an
investment group and like the the
previous owner was very much he was he
was growing the company with the
intention of selling it that was always
what he was gonna do but now that we're
with an investment group ever
thing has its eye on growth to the point
that we acquired another company this
year almost exclusively because that
counts as nothing but profit and so with
all the other stuff that was going on
with the changeover there was a lot of
turmoil a lot of hiccups and it wasn't a
great year and the way they cushion that
was by simply buying another company and
then that company's profits for the
entire year are on our books which means
on paper we grew when all we did was
throw money and buy another company we
didn't grow we consumed but that counts
as growth it's on paper it always has to
be on paper that you are getting bigger
year over year over year over year but
that is literally unsustainable this is
also the core root of so much of what is
wrong with the video game industry right
now because the reason that video game
publishers are pushing not just
pre-order bonuses not just continuous
service not just loop boxes not just
season passes but all of it plus annual
sequels to these things is because it's
not enough to make a game and sell the
game it has to be a continual stream
because the video game industry reached
more or less honestly it's natural
ceiling of how much money it was going
to make producing games and selling
games so the only way for these
companies to continue to grow which they
have to because they have investors is
to find ways to get more money out of
the customers they already have because
they have reached the point where there
really wasn't too many more customers
that they could get but they could
squeeze more money other ones they have
and thus you have all these additional
tactics that are currently going on and
it's throttling the industry and the cut
because the thing is
when a company has investors that
company's customers are the investors
their customers who they sell things to
are an asset but they don't care about
satisfying them they care about
satisfying the investors if they happen
to satisfy their paying customers fine
that's not the point
it's never the point
sounds very clean game Ross yeah bit
smash the system after we get paid haha
I would prefer a similar system to Star
Trek guiding force of our world is money
but not in Star Trek if you want deeper
explanation just say so I know that um
start well Star Trek the reason Star
Trek is a utopia is it exists in a post
need society which is why in Star Trek
they're able to basically get away from
capitalism all together and not even
have to have money because there's no
scarcity anymore they have they have
replicators they have you know medical
tricorders they have dealt with all the
inherent problems of feeding clothing
and keeping the populace healthy and
once you've done that once everyone's
accounted for you you can die a lot of
this stuff back because you realize oh
we don't need to be sorted into winners
and losers because we're in a position
where everyone can just win so at least
that's my understanding of Star Trek as
a as a utopia it is very much a post
need society though personally all my
strong opinions on politics are social
politic hang on lost it backing up I
don't know nearly enough about economics
to have opinions on them I have a few
but not many well I mean this is part of
what you know I did that video or I've
done a couple of videos now talking
about how when companies you know show
support for lgbtq+
it's not because they actually want to
do that it's because they think it's the
better investment they think long term
it'll yield better returns and I have
said that that doesn't negate the value
of what they're doing that's still
something that should happen even if
it's for quote-unquote the wrong reasons
but it does mean if they ever feel it is
more economically viable to oppress
lgbtq+ people that they will do that
instead so you know the motivations
being what they are that is still a
point of concern for me again it doesn't
mean that
I am NOT going to embrace whatever
change comes about because of the
motivations they have but basically any
company with investors cannot make a
principled stance if they know what
they're doing they're very good about it
they can present something as if it's a
principled stance but it's always a case
of they either take a stance that they
believe is in their best economic
interests or they take no stance because
they don't think any of them have a
clear economic benefit so a company that
is that does not have to answer to
investors a company that is wholly owned
can make the decision I'm going we're
going to support this because it's the
right thing to do because they don't
have to answer to investors now that is
not for me to say that's not me saying
that wholly owned companies are somehow
magic and wonderful and great they're
not they can be incredibly horrible and
skeevy as well but at least they have
the option of making less money in
exchange for doing the right thing
because if you have investors making
less money is never an option are you
familiar with Alex belt men aka I hate
everything I know the name I don't know
his stuff at all I'm glad we're talking
about this but I'm just dreading the
not-so-great they're not so great ute
what's a ute love your videos question
what kind of post-capitalist society do
you envision to be possible in the near
future now that um well first of all
thank you very much appreciate the super
chat those are always appreciated um I
don't have the answer but
nobody needs as much money as the
wealthiest in this country and in the
world have nobody needs that much money
and they definitely don't need more but
everything they do is geared towards
getting more than they already have so
like I how do we tackle that I don't
know tax the rich I'll just say that
flat-out but I mean I'm not a politician
and I'm not a I'm not a political
science junkie I have my opinions and I
can certainly look at a system and go
well that's not working which in many
ways I almost feel like that's my
superpower and it it gets people annoyed
with me um because like what I what I
but I watch trailers unless it
completely blows me away I pretty much
always go you know what there's this
thing that was in the trailer I could
see how that might be a bad idea or
gives me that that might be a problem
and it brings people down and annoys
people a bit but I do that with
everything if I'm at a meeting at my job
and and a presentation goes on they're
like here's what we're planning on doing
the first thing my brain maps out
whether I say it or not but the first
thing my brain maps out is the ways in
which this could fail that's not to say
that I automatically assume something
will fail it's just that's what i zero
in on that's the first thing my brain
isolates what is wrong not what's right
but what's wrong now as a person so I
balance my life I try to not overly
focus on that consciously but
unconsciously that's the first thing
always so you know when you ask me how
do we make a better society
I can maybe point you to some of the
stuff that needs to be fixed the best
way to fix it I mean that's always the
sticking point isn't it because as much
as everyone has gotten very invested in
the dichotomy of the left and the right
there are times when the left and the
right are
at the same thing and both see the same
problem just not the same solution to
that problem so that's that's always the
sticking point finding the problems is
not that hard I'm willing to do the easy
work
can we just bring back the guillotine um
I'm not gonna advocate for that
personally not even as a joke you know
that you guys really make jokes about
how at this point the rich are so
obscenely wealthy that yeah they should
be thanking their lucky stars that the
common folks are not burning their
houses down but I'm never gonna advocate
for that just just much
oh I'm very very gay I as Randy as I can
be I do try and be careful about what I
say my words as strange a concept as
that might be okay so oh she were coming
Double Trouble is crawling on my list of
my favorite characters from Shira and
the princesses of power I wish that I
liked them more than I did I really do
and like their last scene with cats room
was great I like Ike right now I kind of
file Double Trouble in the same category
as Connor from angel which is I like
what they do to the story I don't
especially like them as a character but
I like their for impact I like the
effect that they have on the narrative
and the other characters I just don't
particularly enjoy them which is a shame
and annoys me and I really wish I did
but you know this will now be the first
thing that I point to do anyone who ever
accuses me like oh you just love you
know whenever there's there's your weird
gender fluid representation you just
don't you never criticize that no I do I
don't really like Double Trouble so but
this this will be a nice nice go to
think for me you know what that you know
it just hit me
I I've dubbed this the anti-capitalist
live stream and I accepted a super chat
earlier and I'll happily accept more and
by the end I'll probably have plugged
the patreon at least twice so like I do
not deny being a capitalist let's be
clear about that I'm aware of my part in
this whole messed up system we need new
concepts to change the conversation
combos about capitalism and alternatives
seems to be stuck because proponents of
both have their arguments nailed down I
mean the thing is and you're not wrong
it's been a long time since somebody has
come up with a new governing philosophy
because basically
capitalism sort of started forming
solidly 1700s 1800s as a concept and as
a national sort of system and you know
you had communism in the early 20th
century that's really kind of and and
the two are inherently at odds like that
they're natural enemies but there hasn't
at least not that I'm aware of there
hasn't been like a major shake-up like a
new core governing philosophy to emerge
since then it's been a while since we've
had a new one and you're right it does
mean that the people who have their
feelings about the capitalism versus
communism which first of all we can meet
in the middle somewhere it doesn't have
to be yeah on everything but anyways you
know people really have their things
laid out there and especially you know
it I really would have thought that as
we got further away from the Cold War
the whole communism versus capitalism
thing would become less of a thing but
it doesn't it hasn't gone away which
really kind of bugs me a lot of people
have a lot invested emotionally and
philosophically and politically and
economically to keep that to keep that
whole thing going
Star Trek utopia was achieved by
shifting the guiding force and
philosophy away from the accumulation of
wealth towards advancing the human race
this came after a terrible eugenics war
oh yeah that's right I forgot how the
eugenics were played into how Star Trek
formed as a society hmm I've got
something that I want to come back to
but I want I want to catch a couple of
these comments here um let's see
American capitalism is predatory
investor capitalism isn't the problem as
much as corporate capitalism
the thing is though investor capitalism
is at the heart of corporate capitalism
it's what built corporate capitalism
into the size that it is and it's the
driving philosophy behind how it
operates so I'm not actually sure you
can detach the two but like things
really went downhill when we had the
Supreme Court decision that basically
ruled that money counts as speech and
therefore companies can express free
speech by spending money because funny
thing about that if you treat money as
speech then suddenly the people with
more money have a much louder voice
thank you very much Elise I appreciate
that capitalism's goal is money
happiness and and what's right just gets
in the way I'm not sure
other wisdom has this on the agenda I
think it's just money I think there's a
presumption that if you have money
you'll be happy but I don't I do think
it is actually a goal in and of itself
you never you never give me your money
only give me your funny paper and in the
middle of negotiations you break down
Beatles lyrics I would have sung that
but then this would get demonetised so
thoroughly loved your morning video
thank you very much Donna I agree with
you have you seen the mandalorian and
heard of the glitchyness of Disney plus
Oh Disney Plus launched today didn't it
so no I I haven't seen any of it yet
and no I hadn't heard it was glitchy so
I might wait on on getting that cuz I'm
I have an eight-year-old I'm guy it's
got all the Disney stuff I'm gonna get
it exactly like to describe Star Trek
it's non currency based demo social
communism in a sense I'm banging the
Star Trek drum pretty hard aren't I you
are John but you know what it's okay if
that's your point of reference I can dig
it so okay so what I was gonna say cuz
you know you're talking Star Trek and
you're talking you know future societies
and there aren't there are very few
utopia futures
fiction stories it's almost always a
dystopia whether it is a post apocalypse
dystopia a cyberpunk
corporate dystopia whatever I actually
had a concept for a setting and I still
haven't decided what kind of story I'm
gonna tell in it of what would on paper
sound like a dystopia but that actually
functions and like I spent a ridiculous
amount of time figuring out okay here's
this core concept that people assume is
terrible is there a way to take that
core concept and actually lay it out so
it would work and yeah I spent a lot of
time a lot of time thinking about that
and and maybe one of these days I'll
actually I'll actually come up with a
story to put in that in that setting but
that was a fundamental exercise my
favorite utopia story is utopia of
course where somebody had to say it you
get a week free trial for any
anti-capitalist look looking to play the
system with Disney plus week free trials
are your friend absolutely I think most
sci-fi dystopia because it is really
serving to analyze current society in a
safe way especially if you look at the
fact that most of the best sci-fi came
out during McCarthyism I'm not sure moso
the best sci-fi did but a lot of good
sci-fi did but let that's sort of the
nature of most speculative fiction it's
usually commenting on the world we have
now by taking certain aspects of it and
going down a logical or sometimes
extreme progression and what that looks
like further down and that is by its
nature is why a lot of science fiction
is bleak and you kind of have to look to
things like science fantasy
which is what things like star wars is
if you want more uplifting sci-fi
because sci-fi that's actually
extrapolated out from the cut world as
it is text pretty much always be
depressing can't imagine why would we
did I can speak with Disney Plus out I
don't know why I had such a hard time
saying that ah on the top of your head
what Disney characters would you
consider to be fellow slytherins well
most of the villains
first of all other than that let me
think who would be slytherins
I'm trying to I'm trying to think of
anybody other than the villains and I'm
coming up a little empty I could sit
here and think about it but you just be
watching me think for a while and I
think that would get very boring the
idea I think oh the idea I think you're
thinking about is a utopia without
technology
if James if you're talking about what
you think my concept that I alluded to
was like no it's completely
technological based but as far as
speculative fiction go yeah the if
technology breaks down sometimes the
stories are happier recently home home
brewed my 3ds free games here like yeah
someone does accuse you of being a
communist can you take a picture where
you pose with a hammer and sickle I
don't have a sickle I have I have a
Captain Hammer shirt that's somewhere
[Music]
because these I'm not the hammer
the hammer is my penis and now I'm
demonetised haha I was quoting something
future YouTube person who will review
this to see if it should stay to
monetized or not I know you don't care
but whatever ah what are your thoughts
on season four of the good place so far
um I'm not completely caught up I think
I've seen more episodes so far and I am
liking it I am digging it I do think
it's probably we would call to end it
this season um because I'm not sure they
could keep going in like it is losing a
little bit of its freshness as it goes
but I think they can they can ride it
through the rest of the season and I'm
excited to see to get to the end of it
Toy Story 2 is turning 20 tomorrow Oh
also Disney's The Little Mermaid is
turning 30 tomorrow Toy Story 2 was
playing at the movie theater when I was
working there as my first job next year
is my 20th high school reunion let that
one sink in I once wrote a dystopian
short fiction that dealt with political
partisanship as being a Republican or
Democrat is part of your identity like
race gender and religion huh interesting
I'm so old I'm like the Crypt Keeper
Freaky Friday reference very nice I love
the good place but this season's the
weakest it might be but I still don't
think it's gonna be bad as an ending
Tiana from Princeton and the frogs of
Slytherin she might be yeah yeah
feasibly I think I feel like Flynn Rider
is try
to be a Slytherin I'm not sure he
actually is but his persona is of one Oh
last episode lace is 90 minutes so
excited oh sweet that's nice
what sort of Oz just turned 80 oh boy
if you pick a returning master which two
would you pick to return I mean I want
Missy back like absolutely if it were
possible oh god oh it's not I mean
really the only ones who can feasibly be
brought back unless they start
introducing some of the some of the Big
Finish exclusive masters into the main
continuity well they could bring they
could bring back um Jacobi so him and
Missy I guess but other than that the
only other viable options are Sims and
Eric Roberts I'm not sure that Jeffery
beavers would be willing to put the
makeup on to do the burnt master again
he's he's little old for it not old to
play the part but little old to have
that much latex shoved on his face I
think I think aladdin and Jasmine are a
Slytherin super couple possibly I was
trying to think jasmine maybe maybe
actually ooh
Ariel's a Slytherin yeah which is
interesting because so is the villain I
hope I don't need to start a new
drinking game but did you review the
mandalorian for God's sake Disney Plus
has been out for a day no I didn't
review it my god people I do still work
a day job you know
I got it Maui is a Slytherin ooh that's
a good one
um Nick from Zootopia
he's a Slytherin in my opinion the best
distributor of foreign animated films
aside from Sony Pictures Classics is gee
kids they have high tastes I tell you
yeah they do pretty good stuff it's
probably easier to list Disney moans who
aren't slytherins Gaston and Frollo are
Gryffindor's yes they are
mother Gothel an evil Hufflepuff you
think I don't know about that one
have you read the Doctor Who season 12
episode blurbs on IMDB nope and I'm not
going to because those can be put in by
literally anybody so and and I know that
because I obtained my own IMDB page so
will you be doing another Big Finish
review anytime soon I mean on point I
will I don't know when I just I just
don't right now have you heard of boom
Studios Power Ranger comics um yes
but I also realize I never really got
into Power Rangers so I'm not sure I
would care very much I'd like the
decayed master not necessarily played by
beaver sings as how Missy died when we
last saw her yeah yeah that would be
viable I mean but like also keep in mind
that with any version of the master it's
feasible to bring any of them back
because it could just be from a gap in
what we know of as their story you have
to be careful about how their encounter
with the doctor gets handled because of
how much they are or aren't supposed to
know about whatever the incarnation of
doctor is but you could theoretically
have any version of the master run into
any doctor in some form as long as you
handle it correctly
feel like I'm gonna sneeze but now that
I've said that I'm probably not going to
do you you mutt you're all dropping the
mandalorian thing on me I didn't make it
a drinking question
mother Gothel is very possessive of
Rapunzel like a version of slither and
he only has Rapunzel because of what
that gives her ie the magic ie the
ability to stay young which is a very
Slytherin motivation it wasn't like she
kidnapped Rapunzel to have a family
which would be a bit more of an evil
helpful thing to do she kidnapped her
because of the magic you know it she
tried to just take her hair if she could
have taken her hair and left the kids
she would have that's that seems pretty
Slytherin to me any actual Canon house
or dings you disagree with um I don't
know if I disagree because the other
thing to keep in mind is always that
personal preference enters into it to a
degree and you know sometimes the
sorting hat sees stuff that maybe the
rest of us don't but I do feel like
Rowling picked you know a both a
stereotypical Hufflepuff and Ravenclaw
and drop them into Slytherin just for
the sake of variety of characters in
there ie Neville is very Hufflepuff and
hermione is very ravenclaw and that's
not to say either of them are devoid of
Gryffindor traits just that like if you
were to ask me based off their
personalities Gryffindor is not my the
top one I would put either of the men
I'm gonna have to check the disk order
in a minute not every youtuber has to
review the mandalorian today besides
it's been it has been seen yet in other
countries right I don't know Donna I
mean this has a compliment but I bet you
could do a good Tommy Wiseau impression
oh hi mark
you're tearing me apart Lisa
I don't know if I could do the
mannerisms am I the only one who thinks
awful puffs have the potential to be the
most dangerous people a lot of bad
things can be done out of loyalty all
the mandalorian um see I would argue and
I have argued Santos is a Hufflepuff
it's a very twisted way of caring about
the universe and valuing life by
destroying half of it I would love to
see McGann's doctor face off against
Delgado's master and an audio either
with repurposed audio or voice actors
impression I do resist the impressions
thing I do get iffy about that but if if
they could pull something together from
existing audio that would be very cool
dark gryffindor is an extremist a dark
ravenclaw is an unethical scientist a
dark Hufflepuff is someone who is
possessive over their loved ones I love
that you didn't bother specify who a
dark slither it is basically because the
assumption is that's how all of us are
that's that gone
I kind of wish Cedric was a Slytherin
mm-hmm that would have been interesting
but it Stan
a capitalist bringing it back no I don't
think he is um Hermione isn't
open-minded enough to be a ravenclaw
also am I the only one who doesn't mind
Harry in the fifth book maybe it's
because I was also an angsty teen when
reading it look I was an angsty teen and
I wasn't that far out of my a C teens
when I read it I I don't need to read
someone who reminds me of when I was
also a jackass I mean maybe that's just
me
I feel like Thanos is ambition and
determination overpowers his love but
that's just me you could easily be right
yes I could I could just as easily be
wrong but I won't
I choose not to entertain that notion
considering that slytherins get a bad
rap a lot I thought it was fair to show
off the dark sides of the other houses
not its core Rebecca I was ribbing you a
little bit don't worry about it have you
ever read the incredible Squirrel Girl
um no I have however read the unbeatable
Squirrel Girl which is awesome
you thought wasn't yard stare doesn't he
doing okay bud you're alright
are you excited for the matrix for I am
curious I want to know more about it I'm
nervous about it the way I'm nervous
about any additional sequel to something
that was very much built to be closed
off and finished but given that it
involves I believe it's lana wachowski
is working on it it at least has my
interest poor Totoro he needs a hug
what's your favorite time of the year my
favorite time of the year is the two
weeks of peak foliage and where I live
it is stunningly gorgeous and it is
literally about two weeks but god is it
beautiful it's beautiful and the weather
is perfect it's like right around 50 60
you you wear a coat or a jacket but
nothing too heavy you don't have to
bundle up but like I look I think I look
cool in a long coat so I like to wear my
long coats it's like it's gorgeous and
so brief I've got a Totoro in another
room but I'm sure I can find something
he's staring in this one my allergies
ruined fall for me oh that sucks the
decayed master would be viable as both
after survival and the TV movie the
master has reverted back to that state I
suppose that's true
the master is also a capitalist and
watched the mint oh my god
are you people okay I got a pop on over
to the discord to see what's going on
there because haha because I myself am a
capitalist hypocrite that I am the
discord is a patreon exclusive perk so
let me pop on over there let's see what
questions might have been a house okay
sounds like you'd be interested in being
a bread tube or do you ever think about
inviting some of them on to very wild
videos first of all all the big bread
tube names are way too big to listen to
me like I'm I'm not gonna name names but
I've tried to reach out to a number of
people over the years to try and
collaborate on something we are a while
related even like people around my
subscriber level or at least a
subscriber level this channel birra has
fewer subscribers but like I never hear
back from anybody so would I want to in
some way collaborate with them yeah
absolutely but I also don't see myself
ever being going out of my way to be a
bread tuber which if people don't know
it's it's sort of the nickname for
left-wing YouTube so it'd be things like
philosophy tube innuendo studios contra
points h-bomb or guy those sorts of
folks but the thing is like I don't I
don't trust myself to do the amount of
research to make those kinds of
arguments well that's why like about as
close as I come to it is talking the
lgbtq+ representation in entertainment
because that's my wheelhouse and I'm
comfortable there research is not my
strong point and I know that I am not
good at sitting down and doing a ton of
research I can do maybe a day's worth of
research to shore up or get
specific data on something that I more
or less already know about but if I'm
starting from scratch it's it's it's a
bad time that's there's the ADHD
creeping in a little bit uh let's see I
think most bread tubers lean towards the
Communists ends of politics but I'm not
entirely sure if that's correct did we
just do monetize the stream before it
even started quite possibly that would
be a record I'm in an interesting
position on capitalism I recognize it
the many harms it produces but I've yet
to hear convincing argument for a better
alternative all the ones that have been
presented to me are pie in the sky with
the English failed to account for human
nature and would therefore break at
leases badly and practice as capitalism
does just in different ways if someone
here has something that would work
better I'm deeply interested in hearing
about and I'm with you mad that's kind
of why my stance is not we have to scrap
capitalism but it is we have to cap the
dang thing there needs to be a ceiling
because unfettered and unrestricted
capitalism is just burn it all down and
sell the ashes for the profit and if
that makes you money that's what will
happen so the thing and I said this way
at the beginning no system unfettered
works everything has to have
restrictions and restraints put into
place because the full-body version
basically every political idea is going
to fall apart and so my basic stance
with capital is why I largely rail
against investment capitalism because
that drives the worst excesses of the
system if that could be dialed back or
we could just get rid of investment as a
thing or at the very least tax the
ever-loving freaking heck out of it
like I I will never shed a tear if Wall
Street executives make 1/3 as much money
as they currently do in the rest goes to
taxes I would be very happy with that
and they still have too much money but
that's sort of the kinds of restrictions
that I want to see put into place
because the lack of a ceiling means that
people are slaughtering the competition
to make a ladder out of the bodies to
try and get on top was that a really
good metaphor or a really bad one I
don't know social democracy or
liberalism the wait is done in Sweden is
working I don't know enough about the
Swedish system Sweden is a capitalist
country just as higher taxes and better
social safety net
well yeah that'd be nice
[Music]
what are your views on Andrew Yang's
financial plan I have not been following
the Democratic debates because I'm not
in a state that votes in the primaries
so I don't really have a reason to I'm
not gonna help determine who the
Democratic nominee is so well I said we
don't participate in the primaries like
we do when the when the when like it
comes down to like the tail end of it
when there's like three people left but
like well I'm not in a state that does
any of the early stuff like cuz there's
place like Iowa New Hampshire and all
these places that you know are have do a
lot of big things early and so a lot of
campaigning happens there doesn't happen
where I am so I just I'd it's and it's
for my own mental best interest to not
get involved too early in the process
because if I burn out
before even in the year the election
freakin happens that that doesn't do me
any favors all right I'm almost caught
up on the discord I think when do we get
to eat the rich in what sauce would you
recommend I would recommend a Bearnaise
sauce personally well with fava beans
and Chianti possibly the stress the
struggle of class against class is a
what struggle a what struggle that is a
Monty Python reference a political
struggle if you get this right you're on
your way to that lounge sweet love it
I'll probably be jumping off the stream
every 10 minutes or so
will you ever make a politics youtube
channel no no because if I had a reason
to rant at a camera about my political
views on a regular basis I would become
an insufferable human being I get to
vent enough about politics just talking
with my family and with Liz
that's enough nobody else needs to hear
that liberal politics on youtubes is a
dangerous thing to do well yeah there's
there's that too what one film property
would you like to see return I also call
myself a cop a calm social capital is
this a philosophy that takes all things
that work in each system all right
interesting enough um probably the like
to see return I don't know as far as
like dormant stuff that hasn't had
anything a while I don't really have
anything off the top of my head
see there are those who worship
capitalism so much that any critique is
seen as communism yeah yeah that's
anyone who is bought into any system so
hard that anything other than 100%
agreement makes you the opposite of that
thing that scares me and that
unfortunately is where a lot of the
political discourses right now and that
really does terrify the ever-loving heck
out of me
have you read any of the Buffy
continuation comics yeah I have I think
I have all of season eight I didn't love
it um so I didn't keep reading after
that what if instead of the Mandalorian
we asked if you've seen and will review
the not boba fett show uh it's the fad
show starring me in fact it's the fact
show and I have lots of great guest it
did it did it to do somebody named me
that thing that I just kind of reference
but switched a name out on by the way
that was a good metaphor before but very
bleak the best metaphor is off in our so
I'll take it probably gonna wrap up soon
I want to shoot a reaction video for the
updated Sonic the Hedgehog trailer and
have that up over on break room of geeks
before I go to bed Sam Mendes is
directing a World War One movie called
1917 it is set to release this Christmas
it looks incredible I mean it might I'm
not really a war movie person it's not
to say there aren't any that I like but
it's just not really my shanwa
broadly speaking I am watching His Dark
Materials and it's fantastic what book
series do you think would make a great
shows especially those that deserve a
second chance after bad adaptations um
I mean I've said before that honestly if
they're ever gonna read apt Harry Potter
that should be on TV not to say that the
movies weren't good they were but I'm
just saying I mean honestly I had kind
of secretly hoped that the Lord of the
Rings going big would have led to some
of the Dungeons and Dragons related
books getting adapted like for me would
have been re Salvador's Drizzt Do'Urden
books I would have been all over that
like the Dark Elf trilogy I'd that's my
jam but oh well
thirty pages into Handmaid's Tale and I
find it very captivating awesome I
haven't read it not really uh not really
motivated to it's 3:00 a.m. so I'm
heading to bed probably a good idea have
a wonderful week and thanks for the
stream thank you for stopping in Jessica
here in New Hampshire it feels like
perfect autumn is getting shorter and
shorter every year I mean sometimes I
guess but I feel I feel like I think
that every year and it hasn't gotten
down to one day yet so it's probably
just a bird perception I love see mortal
engines try it again with a much lower
budget like 2d animation they could have
been a lot closer to the books in terms
of tone yeah I remember seeing the
trailers for that and going this this
looks like a mess skulduggery pleasant
should be a TV show don't know that one
the author also wrote a short Doctor Who
story okay cool
your father daughter Pokemon costumes
reminded me of when my dad was the can
the Hat and my sister and I were thing
one and thing two oh that's really sweet
what should the next Wizarding World
Series be about I don't know I'm losing
my enthusiasm for continuations not for
the series as a whole because you got my
kiddo into it and we're reading those so
you know I'm rediscovering my love for
the original books but yeah you won't
succeed on YouTube if you don't have
Mandalorian reviews Spamalot reference
Magnus chase Disney already fumbled
Percy Jackson where the person was
Tuesday I can't remember I'm not arguing
I just don't remember that still waiting
for a proper Hitchhiker's Guide I stand
by my stance that it does not work in
visual medium because what's great about
it doesn't translate because it was
truly great about it is not what happens
but the way it is described and you get
some of that in the radio you get a ton
of that in the novels and I personally
am of the opinion that the novels are
the superior version of Hitchhiker's
Guide for that exact reason because the
actual events while cool and fun and
funny pale in comparison to the way that
Douglas Adams describes them the
descriptions the metaphors the analogies
used to talk about what is going on
whereas in a visual medium all you can
do is depict it and you lose his
narrative voice no I really I don't want
to see any more adaptations of
hitchhikers ever is it novel to read a
novel about a novel well no because
writers love to write about writers so
there's probably lots of novels about
novels ever heard the original radio
drama of Hitchhiker's Guide I have it's
good stuff
I still prefer the the novels though
actually you want to be specific what I
prefer more than anything else is the
audiobook as read by Douglas Adams what
so good have you ever thought of doing a
stream with cell specs so the thing is
like I don't I don't know how to get
ahold of these people and set this stuff
up I'm like I'm a crap networker and one
of the point I don't even know how that
would work
given that she doesn't appear on screen
with things but like in general broadly
speaking I'd love to do more
I'd love to get more stuff with other
youtubers going and there's a lot that I
follow like I'm these days I am casually
talking with with Ian over at passion of
the nerd but and we have been like we
should figure something out but like
trying to actually figure something out
it's hard man it's hard not sure about
the show but the hitchhiker's movie was
smart
using narration of good lines and some
key concepts with Stephen Fry know it's
like yes but that's a that's like a
Cliff Notes version of what's great
about the book anyway hi hi Sami I'm
actually just planning to wrap up pretty
soon you need a PR flack right yeah yeah
like I there's a lot of stuff like in in
an ideal world where I could afford
basically a full-time assistant who
could work my schedule and like it could
mean something for me to say I'll have
my people call your people but I don't
and I have to do everything myself and
I'm not great at it
I had a lot of it Oh Ben you in a world
we all know that drama sells to start a
feud okay that it that's one thing that
I am drawing all yourself okay no
Carolyn you're a wonderful mod and
you're a good friend and I always
appreciate that you do nudge me and you
do help it's also not your job so
anytime you need to stop doing it you
have you have the right in the ability
to do that so yeah sorry I do a lot
myself how about that yeah no I if
there's one thing that I am gonna draw a
line in the sand on I have no interest
in starting or contributing or fueling
the fire of a YouTube view
and I say that as someone who has been
targeted by other youtubers twice at
least that I know of and I've had people
tell me oh you should like have a
conversation with and like I never named
these people and I'm not gonna do it now
because I refuse to participate in this
nonsense and I've had people usually
someone who claims and of both mine and
these other people stuff is like oh well
you should have like a like a debate or
like a Skype call or livestream with
these people like No No why I don't see
any good coming of that so ya know
YouTube drama that is of all the stuff
yeah I I've had plenty of times over the
years and I said like I will never do
that and then at some point I was like
no closest I ever came was talking about
Channel awesome and even that was kind
of on sufferance because I had to do
that because it was occupying my brain
space and I had to purge it but and
annoyingly it probably would be good for
this channel because those two videos I
made on channel awesome still some of my
most viewed stuff which is infuriating
cuz I don't want to do that I really
don't I knew I would miss most the
stream but thought I stopped in to see
if everyone was behaving themselves
well it wouldn't be any fun if we were
doing that would it
debates are for a niche area and are
morph respectively yeah not like the
whole concept of a public debates is
something I like here's the thing there
are people out there who I would never
agree to have a public debate with but
there but some of those people I would
want to sit down like over a cup of
coffee privately with no audience and no
cameras and try and have a real
conversation with them because the big
part of the problem with the whole
debate thing is that it is performative
by its nature because both sides are
going in already having decided what
their stances and to concede any point
is to appear weak and appear to lose
faith in your argument and that can cost
you the faith of your audience if you
have built yourself in any way on the
certainty of your convictions so the
instant that you know there's an
audience and there's camera the
incentive is to never back down and
every yield ground because it's damaging
to your brand to do it and I don't have
any interest in participating in that
some of these people I would like to sit
down and have like a real conversation
with them just to pick their brains in a
way that I think would have least have a
shot of them not being knee-jerk
defensive because that's what they have
to be for the audience but because I
have no anticipation of getting that I
just walk away I'm not interested I just
hadn't said hi in a while stuff that
happened I just wanted to let you know I
still watch your stuff but life
sometimes be getting in the way of
things yes like life rather frequent
li be doing that alright I said I was
gonna wrap up and I keep I keep not so
Oh Oh Carol a nice catch
troll slang nicely done I just got here
is the name a joke
no no it's not you're probably gonna
have to go back and watch the archive of
this to get the the full proper rant
because I kind of burned through it see
start a fake feud with Stu bagful that
that that would be something now the
question is would I be feuding with real
world Stuart or avatar Stuart or would
they be ganging up on me just watch out
for the living flesh supercomputer
that's all
is there anything your characters
inherit from you usually um well I mean
when I'm writing fiction to some degree
so like the the novel that I'm working
on with my cuisine right now there's two
characters in it that the the basic
framework by which I figured out their
how they were gonna behave in the story
was one of them behaved the way I would
like to think I would in those
circumstances and the other one behaved
how I actually think I would behave
under those circumstances so sometimes
it's kind of deliberate but other than
that I don't know not always about a few
between Daniel and Vera oh we get along
so well most of the time I wonder how
many people are just confused with that
an asinine question but here do you
think hitchhikers takes place in the
universe um I'm actually that's on the
docket to eventually tackle as a video
to talk about the connection
and how viable it would be for them to
be the same universe cuz there are some
connections between them so I actually
do plan to dedicate a video to that one
of these days no idea when but it is on
my it is on my list red door 2020 any
thoughts didn't know it was a thing so
no not really
I'd be more concerned about starting a
few with the flesh supercomputer to be
honest well I'm pretty sure we're all on
the living flesh supercomputers hit list
it's just a matter of when you will do
anything for you to do that dr. Simon's
wrote a few classic KU stories for those
who don't know well not only did he
write a few has a KU story he's injected
explicit references which got reiterated
under Davies so like someday someday
video you don't maybe maybe I'll do that
for towel Day next year maybe maybe
that's what I'll do um but yeah I am I
am gonna wrap it up there so thank you
everybody for tuning in to watch me rant
about the system in which we live and of
which I am an active participant never
said I wasn't a hypocrite so hope
everyone has a good evening I hope that
you've had at least a week hope that
your new Disney Plus subscription isn't
witching and and thanks for listening
listening me get on a bit more of a
political soapbox that I usually do try
not to have that be the norm but it's
just kind of where my head was tonight
so thanks a lot for tuning in remember
that you are beautiful
you're valid you are loved
you're the council I'm just running
meetings